Hello everybody my is Markiplier, and welcome back to Doom.
Now I have a funny feeling, that we're probably pretty close to the CyberDemon-hello...
Hi!??!?!!!!!!!
Who's out there? Oh-hello:)
Hi friend, I'll be with you in just uh moment, wait for me
I mean not like you're gonna go anywhere, but i might get rekt scrub mlg 420
Hello, is there a friend out there that wants a gruh-nad-ae?
You dead? You'd better be dead. Boink!
No? *Pubumph*
*Pluff* God dammit you're too tough!
You're just too stronk, unlike me. Well I mean I'm too strong too-hey buddy
Heh friend, gonna be hard to avoid you in this hallway
Apparently someone said that their back is actually a weak spot, so hitting them in their face is totally unnecessary and stupid,
So I need to pump... shells,
I was about to say pump shells up their butt, but that-that implicates a few things that don't wanna be gettin into-
*Hebyubuh*
hmm, seems like they may be gearing me up for something, not a hundred percent sure what.
But I hope it's cybery!
And demony!
The ideal combination in my mind.
Eeuh! It's getting progressively more bloody and apparently there's a containment breach.
I don't know what that is, unless that's pure argent energy which means that's pure hell - what is that up top?
Woah, what is that? Woah, do I have anything that can zoom in on that? I do! What is that? Oh, that's a summoner!
(inhale)
So they're channeling argent energy through a summoner but for what purpose? Is that gonna help us summon in more demons or something?
-they're obviously doing, a lot of experimentation on these demons so it makes sense that there's gonna be some radical things to be seen.
Oh hi! (haha)How're you doin?!
Huh, that's a lot of knowledge to be having and relying on an unknown person in an unknown tomb based on some dusty old tomes about how cool I am.
I mean I appreciate the vouch of confidence but, to be honest I dunno if you should've trusted it.
Okay- "Security station activation required", that's-oh hello, I'll be with you in a second.
Those looks like some bizarre rooms, but am I supposed to do this?
Okay- So the argent energy channeled through the summoner means that this IS the Lazarus Wave